allora sono passati mille anni da quando
è uscito venerdì 13 questo questo è il
video più bello che io abbia mai fatto
sfera di thaci bello giuro
buona visione ragazzi tenetevi forte non
sono io no sono veramente io ringrazio
esiste ragazzi vi devo aprire la faccia
ce la mette la macchina ragazzi ma non
volevo essere io volevo essere tutti
tranne jason ista partita maledizione
mandate una botta giuseppe chiari giusy
malato con un lato ci sto mollato perché
se il mio grazie va ai una gara capita
la macchina ragazzi sono pochi ma
andiamo ma non c'è giudei devi dirlo
tutto fatto
c'hai il parlamento come sarà invece
andando ecco cosa ci ha sempre chiesto
non andava in casa tirati che ho messo
le trappole a coppia
ma che succede ciao giuseppe ayala che
vale logan cosa fa quello no poi la
gente uccisa giuseppe scusa giusta
sapere ma è l'unico modo per scappare la
macchina dalla merda come si fa
non sono capace uccidere ha lasciato
bravo a sfondo a questo vieni qua lei
qui adesso dice che è fermo come sono
certo
[Musica]
ma chi è questo di qua ma chi è questo
che corre la spiaggia chi è come
telefono lingua mandarina acqua male che
sei falso
come si sa la pasta che guarda milano
massei caparezza al gemelli
oddio è tutto nero non s'è visto niente
ma da cosa ha ucciso un altro cosa è
successo ha ucciso anche sul quale era
fortissimo minano come bisogna montare
una macchina auto cascata ho beccato
qualcuno sulla macchina o mais è
comparso no no no ma gli date una botta
in testa
cos'è che risulta un parlato il tipo che
cos'è che hai detto sta dicendo non
uccidermi ma io ammazzo
suri è morto stefano è morto ma è
rivissuto perché i tomi giardini jarvis
come si trovano poi apparire così dal
nulla
celato miliardi così lasciato la
spiaggia ma basta io ho scolpito e di
morte non andata giù sven erik ha vinto
la batteria ti ammazzo prima aspetto più
cambia madre chiave è l'unico modo per
scappare questa macchina ce n'è un'altra
però il mio dio ragazzi che ami ce la
farai mai amati bellissimo
madonna si è salvato tantissimo e tre
ragazze uno che sta facendo una cosa
importante non può che siamo in ottimi
una volta fare più dire la stava facendo
[Musica]
perché l'hai detto tu non massacrate ma
vabbè magari avevano avrei deciso
comunque regata che lo sta puntando
quello è morto si faceva il viaggio must
in tre ragazzi io voglio ammazzare
questi vi dice che trasporta si è
immaginato così qua dentro
ok ma se che non ho capito niente di per
una società scatenino stefano stefani
no non è vero sì però non è vero mi
nascondevo del panino hai sparato a caso
ha chius parato e panino clinico puoi
essere qua non sei tu allora
ma cosa cosa va in acqua grande ma cosa
fai in acqua
va bene tutto miliardi prendere ma non
sei tu tommy chi è questo c'è un nuovo
coniugare perché ucciso ma chi uccide ma
non è il tuo parole atomi giardi quello
che era mara l'altro il bisogno di
stefano
ho sbagliato come la macchina è ormai mi
sono lasciato via quindi ho fatto una
cazzata ma domani si troverà la tattica
come hai fatto
ma le macchine sono tutti e due in
utilizzate con america di stefano e
sasha e geniale abbiamo certo nato
commissione stiamo creando abbastanza
valore non ci proverà in cui vincere
com'è possibile dove servono è arrivato
il momento di uscire sarebbe arrivato il
momento di scelta bye bye te io mi scusi
dov'è stefano canale dove stefanuto
davvero giù fermato m voleva aiutare a
far sì che insieme con malata o quasi ma
dentro non fermerebbe totale con queste
ricordiamo la residenza ha preso la
macchina ha messo la batteria messo la
benzina mentre scritto sta mandando via
tuveri dove sei ora ti pago il tubo è
vano non dovevi non dovevi nobel io
andrea la barca comunque di marca c'è
una barca e frecce una barca sì ma dove
c'è una barca come fa questa quale avere
tutta sta qua non prenderle lika non
prende non serve l'elica nota
elica stefano peccato il coso dall'altra
parte e mori è successo dov'era barca ma
non c'è nessuna barca qua come ma sta
partendo la macchina a chi è stato ma la
macchina
uno schiaccia il fratellino come si
lascia presa con la rinomata my soul
azienda non lo sto provando i pasti giu
roma butta fra cui versa la macchina
guarda come i am abend faro latinos e
livello tutto quasi provare st si guarda
com'è fatta come hai fatto a yemen da
sipra i petardi lì per terra i primi poi
il 12 30 questo io non ci voglio bene
non può farvi vedere ora ti prego
abbiamo a chi anche perchè davanti se
non so ma no ma lo chiama la super
inizio di una trappola america è entrato
però nel sedile passeggeri erano poi
schizzare su quell altro aspetto io
spingo spingo io la macchina a farlo non
può morire il caso quindi note
dall'altro il governo non capisco
neanche dove sei
tucci
alla fine c'è stato uno switch quando
stefano andata divieto non esiste più e
stato bellissimo e stato bellissimo
signori questo era venerdì 13 con i
mezzi è stato un genoa si può dire
questa parola
no no diciamo che siamo certi ragazzi
iscritti di creare se usate mi piace e
noi ci vediamo come sempre aru prossimo
massa non si può dire niente
beh ragazzi
[Musica]